all right everyone just heard what Newt
said about the future of the GOP
Presidential race joining me now to
react one of the men he spoke about
Vivek ramaswamy 2024 Republican
presidential candidate Vivek nice job
last night they were all after you but
you heard what Gingrich just said a few
moments ago the race is over it's
essentially over
um and the candidates one by one need if
they want a future in politics they need
to start backing Trump drop out and you
know you'll have a big future in
politics your response to Newt
there's some things I admittedly agree
with and there's some things I disagree
with the things that I agree with are
that I don't think last night's debate
was actually very useful having
second-tier candidates in the current
field and I'm admittedly among them
right now in polling tear each other
down that's not useful to our party
versus actually a rich policy debate
however everybody else is making their
case versus Trump by bashing him and
Monday morning quarterbacking some
decision he made my view is different I
acknowledge he was the greatest
president of the 21st century so far but
I have something that he doesn't Laura
and it's really simple I'm young I have
fresh legs I'm able to reach the next
Generation in a way that Trump cannot
that's undeniable and that's how we're
going to take the America first movement
to the next level but I think everybody
in this race needs to be able to at this
point stop messing around tearing each
other down and clearly answer the
question what do you bring to the table
that Trump doesn't it has to be America
First candidate that's the nominee and
that's my answer yeah you're right
you're right about about that and and
Vivek I don't think anyone doubts that I
mean I certainly don't right you're
extremely bright and extremely
impressive
um the yougov poll that just I guess it
was released yesterday The Economist
Hugo poll has you polling nationally at
five percent
um that's 46 percentage points lower
than Trump
and again not to take away from you know
your own success and I think you I mean
coming coming from the world of business
and never being in a political debate
before I I it's it's amazing I I really
admire all of you get up on stage and do
what you did last night but at some
point
um if you want a future in politics you
want those Mega people to say yeah we
know something when he could have stayed
in he decided to put the country first
and start campaigning with Trump and
that's what newt's essentially saying
and at some point you're gonna have to
make that decision you are going to make
that decision at some point
my whole point is I'm an America First
conservative not a trump first
conservative and not a Vivek first
conservative and so I'm one person in
this race I'm not tearing anybody else
down I'm focused on what are we running
to what does it mean to be an American
and Laura I personally do believe it is
going to take someone of the Next
Generation to reach Young Americans for
whom we're doing this I'm doing this for
my two sons and their generation and I
think that's what it's going to take
first of all to win this election by
large margins but second of all to
reunite this country it will take
somebody whose best days are still ahead
in life to see a country whose best days
are still ahead of itself and so I do
that by praising president Trump because
I think that's the right thing to do to
recognize his record but I'm young I
have fresh legs that's the difference
and that's going to be the case I make
to the voters that it will be in America
First candidate from the Next Generation
that leads us forward all right Vivek
it's always great having you on thank
you so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else